[Music]
okay we back
way back and we're ready to do episode
five it's 42 minutes long
episode 5 is 42 minutes long
that's insane
wow
a 42 minute long
all right it's a big episode
big big big big big episode
is it so frozen for a bunch of people
uh okay it looks like we're back
maybe maybe
oh here we go okay it looks like we're
back
okay we're about to start it it's 42
minutes
long which is pretty awesome
pretty awesome 42 minutes long
it's a big episode
so anybody who's ready to
anybody who's ready to press play we're
about to press play
we are pat feet friends we're back
okay cool um we're about to start it
uh yeah the episode it's
42 minutes long and not really right
because they put the like end credits
and they're they're super long the end
credits are like
i don't know they're like seven eight
minutes long
but all right we are going to
what's up david allen protect us west
texas um we are going to start
we're going to start it so if you have
it
we're gonna press play is everybody
ready we're pressing play
put my screen up here now actually
so i can see this
all right we are about to start this
if you have it open we're going in three
two
one just a recap
previously on one division
that was such a cool opening scene
what fluffed everybody saying woof
[Music]
it's just doing the recap of what
happened last time
it's an episode three recap it's not
even a
there we go that's that's episode all
right here we go
nope marvel intro
[Music]
all right let's see what we got
oh it's like a full house intro it's
like
it's super 80s 90s
[Laughter]
they've got the two twins right here
keep a mirror behind me harold
twins
twins
hahahahaha
it's so normal after last
maybe she said maybe we just need some
help and agnes appears
jazzercise that's so 80s and 90s
auntie agnes is here and i have a couple
tricks up my sleeve hmm
[Music]
[Music]
what
well they got weird right away
that got weird fast
agnes just acted like she knew she was
in a tv show
another mention of ralph
so
vision is starting to
no the children aren't there
whoa their kids are big already
[Music]
kids aren't big they're like i don't
know three years old two years old i
don't know how
old kids are
it's like a almost like a bob ross
introduction
no well there's nothing there to show
new jersey west view west view new
jersey west view new jersey
oh wow that's crazy
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Laughter]
there you go
the babies the twin boys look they're
grown up already
wow
introducing tommy wow he's like
well he already grew up this might be
the halloween episode guys
and billy tommy and billy
the kids are i'm gonna say they're like
three or four
they might grow up again real quick
right here though
oh wait we're talking to monica and beau
oh man
grief
jimmy wu and darcy
so they're meeting that sword right now
she's principal victimizer
oh this is really cool kind of showing
their past
oh he looks evil
oh
oh i thought they were gonna finally
under her mind control
[Music]
interesting
oh please show me something cool
oh here we go
yes i knew it
whoa
oh
dude this is insane
holy whoa
wow
how does that work
billy and tommy
what did they put in the water
that's a puppy
oh they just got super intense and then
now it's super lighthearted again and i
want it just to be intense
oh and look at that
vision is getting very suspicious
very suspicious
sniffy
hmm
oh wanda just said she's tired of hiding
eh
whoa the twins just like changed on
command
on command like they did it themselves
what
that's funny
she said photons
okay she got her coffee
yes darcy got coffee jimmy will gave it
to her
who's the aerospace engineer that would
be up for the challenge
[Music]
oh
no way that's so cool to say
things are getting like super
interesting
yep
whoa
rewriting reality
i don't know what that means
vision's at work now and he's talking to
i don't uh
ra ra i don't remember his name his
actual name
oh my gosh
email
whoa
[Music]
whoa
him
[Music]
this is insane
vision just i mentioned this in my last
video so i'll mention it now it's not a
spoiler vision just awakened
one of the guys he worked with and like
he remembered everything
and he asked vision for help
everybody still thinks it's wanda doing
everything and maybe it is but
i still think she's under control of
something
wanda and vision are gonna fight like
fight i bet
no do you have a brother mom
i do
no way no no no no no way no way no way
oh no no no no no no
what is happening
[Music]
hmm
oh no no no no no no
hey what's up sean how's it going man
holy crap this is insane no oh my gosh
oh my gosh this is insane this is insane
wait what does that say oh oh this is
the scene
this is the scene they teased us about
hold on
oh my gosh what's about to happen
oh
yeah that's oh
holy crap
whoa
wanted just
her accent's back
oh
[Music]
oh
[Laughter]
oh
whoa
what in the heck
that's funny
it's the same
the same actress from the last
commercial
oh my gosh guys this is ins this is
literally inside
and i don't want to spoil it for people
who don't want spoilers but it's
literally
insane
wanda looks actually crazy
did he really
that is crazy
wow
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa
um
do
whoa
this is getting insanely intense
that is true there are no other children
in this town
who is at the door
what the hell
what the hell
what the hell
oh my gosh
i just finished it oh my gosh
what oh my gosh
what the heck guys if you don't want
spoilers you need to leave
because i can't stop everybody in the
chat for posting them
because holy freaking
crap what the heck
are you serious and they straight up
said it they said did she recast
picture oh my gosh we gotta get with
we gotta get with supes and uh brad holy
crap hold on hold on hold on
[Music]
oh my gosh
okay hold we have to get with super wow
wow
what that's the just
wow i am
baffled i am just baffled
oh my gosh are we serious
marvel freaking did that
wow i am
i'm in awe right now
i am in awe right now
like really
that's crazy
one second guys
uh
[Music]
you guys hear me
hold on i'm getting in this hey guys can
you hear me
they can't hear me yet hold on
hello can you hear me
i can't hear anyone
well that's not working
why can't i hear anything
hello
well that works but i can't hear anybody
oh it's because okay
wow hey okay can you guys hear me
oh my gosh
what is even happening i don't
understand like
oh my gosh that's it's insane
this show is incredible it's amazing
dude this is honestly one of the
greatest shows
oh my gosh and we were just talking
about when she comes out of the pocket
reality and throws the drone
yeah their feet yeah i mean she loves
them
[Music]
that's it's like it's insane
dude i thought she was gonna kill him oh
yeah
hey brian's more thanks for the donation
super appreciate that
what in the like the way that they said
the way that the darcy literally said
did she recast pedro i'm like so
now i'm like okay there's nothing marvel
won't do
yeah no
this is just a recasted version of pedro
because guess what so many people are
going to get this episode for them
because this is about to grow up on
social media this is growing up as we
speak right now
yeah it really is
my god
wow yeah um
joel reed thank you so much for the
donation but yeah
what made wanda's accent come back i
don't know but i'm glad it came back
um
version of herself and agent voltron
this bro this is why just when we think
we know what the biggest thing is going
to be
we're not even getting close no and
i'm so glad they showed i'm
i'm so glad they showed the part where
he awakened norm
because that was a note in the last
episode you know what i mean
um under like you know norm's profile it
said notes or whatever and it said you
know when vision awakened him
so i'm so glad it showed that because i
was like did we miss that like
what exactly is happening so dude
she attacked sword and stole visions
corpse yeah yo that was a shot from the
traders brad that we were talking about
yeah coming out of that thing
yep coming out of the dome man
i didn't expect it to be in this episode
it looked like she was carrying
something too
so uh it makes sense now that it was
drone i thought
it was gonna be a body of some kind so
uh wow that sequence of of her in the
reality
looking up and their eyes turning red
oh man dude that was wild but i didn't
expect
her to go pull out just like all right
i'm taking the fight to you
let's go you want to talk let's talk
stay out of my house she says
yeah man and i want to make it very
clear that just because wanda has
recasted
the aetro and his authentic reality and
it's evan peters
we can still very much see everyone
taylor johnson come back oh for sure
oh for sure what's what's the thought
process there though
and the kids the kids brought it up the
kids brought up
you know how wanda mom do you have a
brother
yeah but what's the thought process
logistically
using evan peters instead of air taylor
johnson
why why would she change his appearance
because she doesn't want to remember the
trauma yeah that could be impossible
fair enough um
so
right yeah i don't think she did that
thanks for the donations
uh
[Music]
yeah oh my god
bro we have 3 000 viewers on stream
right now this is absolutely insanity
thank you guys for tuning in this is
history right here yeah this is
people will look back on these live
streams right here because this
history has been made tonight
god man wow yeah
how about that scene where where the dog
died and wanda was talking to her kids
about
death yeah and that's that that was
intense but like
i i found it i'm curious to hear her say
you know there are rules because
it clearly looks like
a human an actual person whereas vision
was a
synthetizoid or whatever they called him
you know so without the mind stone he's
dead you know so i think that's an
interesting point to make but i also
think like pietro
i think the dog died to really bring
that trauma to the forefront
right so i think whoever is in control
brad i saw a dog and i was like it's dr
strange
it's the money it's the buddy it's the
funny it's strange
dude man i i uh but i i think that i
i think once again the pietro thing and
the dog thing
i think those are instances and events
that specifically happen to push her
further and further from the light yeah
sorry i'm having like audio problems i'm
trying to fix them
oh dude
this this is heating up so much
especially with vision i feel like
vision is really kind of like the
driving force
that's like you know obviously there's
other driving forces with sword getting
involved
and stuff but vision constantly
questioning wanda
constantly bringing it up and constantly
having not not being afraid to have that
conversation
that's what's really going to set all of
this off yeah
[Music]
and he's going to try to leave so my
question to you is
one does want to stop him before he
leaves or does he get through and then
immediately revert back to his corpse
and fall to the ground
that would be crazy i don't think he's
going to be able to leave
i think she pulls him back in yeah i
don't think she's going to let him leave
either but that's only going to make
this situation even more
uh abrasive right yeah he's gonna then
he's gonna come out hurt
right because he already kind of did
right so when he flew up in the air in
the living room
either and this is a good easter egg
uh thank you
another thing too guys for sure the kids
are like
shards of mephisto or something because
she can't control the kids yeah who was
monica referring to when she said she's
assuming
and she made like a face when he
mentioned captain marvel yeah she was
pissed
yeah man like it wasn't like a good face
so i'm sure there's like
closure that has to be made there we'll
see probably saying captain marvel 2
or more in this who knows
it's they're doing such a good job i
mean it's like insane
and once again the the leader of sword
he's an israelite
he's a terrorist this that again
i didn't think they would go for like
the stereotypical like all right
evil you know evil like dictator
director kind of thing
but uh it seems that they're going that
route because he seems to
have like some mild intent towards wanda
and he's gonna make things just more
difficult for everyone behind the scenes
from monica jimmy darcy yeah he
there is an uh ulterior motive there for
him for sure
yeah but the question is what is it
did he really think he was gonna take
out wanda with the drone
hold up bro what what if he's rough
what if he's mephisto he could be
i think that's a pretty big theory it
was all about killing wanda
yeah it wasn't about surveillance it was
about sending this drone didn't
kill her yeah that's the thing like
mephisto would know that he's not gonna
kill wanda maximal with a throne
with a missile like that's that's
child's play
right so this could have been done
specifically
to get her pissed off to come out and
show her true
you know colors and push her
further and further away
and that's his objective man because
that that's his that's mephisto's
objective to get
wanda to push her over the edge
bro she's there she's she's long past
the edge at this point
holy crap it's just a matter of
releasing that that energy bro
again they they and they kind of had
that debate for us
i'm like who's the most powerful avenger
yeah i love you
killed thanos she could have killed
thanos you know without touching him
yeah
yeah i love that so do could it could it
have been
um to catboy thanks for the dunno could
it have been billy and tommy who brought
back pedro
because they seemingly have
some power um
how much control over that reality i
don't know but
could have been billiard tommy possibly
and
i don't know
this is marvel entertainment at its
finest ladies and gentlemen
bro i saw that silver hair and i had a i
had a little heart attack on stream bro
oh my god
i was like no no and well
she she even said that when when the
door knocked vision looked at her and
was like
oh let me guess you're interrupting this
important conversation again and she's
like i didn't do that
yeah man she said yeah whoever did
whoever recasted pietro it definitely
wasn't her because she was surprised she
said it wasn't her
and it was someone else and um
dude it's just it's wild and once again
agnes always there when it always
doesn't happen
always there the dog dies agnes finds it
you know it's just very just she's
definitely suss
yo but at the beginning of that episode
you know
they had kind of like a truman show
scene almost
or it was like uh you wanna you want to
do that again should we
read that
[Music]
holy cow yo some people on my chat are
saying the director is a scroll
oh yeah i thought that i should do that
yeah
i could see that yeah man that would be
awesome
nice little segue for secret invasion do
we think it's a scroll
or mephisto
without more significance to the plot
but that could be an awesome way to
segue
secret invasion so but here's my
question now too now that evan peters
aka pietro is back in the show are we
going to see him next episode or was
that literally
just a flighty moment
yo another person is saying was monica
referring to reed richards yeah i
i caught that too some people were
thinking that
some people have said like yeah
professor x will come in at the end
i hope so and thanks for the donut to
say that um
because that would be absolutely insane
um
someone said there's a fiery figure
drawing on the fridge
hold up anyone know the time stamp for
that anyone notice how agnes sprayed
something over the babies and they
suddenly
were able to start aging quickly oh
yeah thank you tommy santana for the
donation
to say that yeah danny i don't know if
that was necessarily like who that gave
them the ability to control
that like to have more control because
wanda was trying to like get them to
stop crying
and she couldn't right and sleep and she
couldn't so they already had like
again like my theory is that again
they're just following the comics
they're shards of mephisto that's why
they can overpower
not necessarily overpower wanda but
wanda just can't control them she can't
control she can control everything else
right right so
why is my hmm
dude and with the piece they're going
bro i wouldn't be surprised if like we
fully see them as like full-fledged
teenagers next episode
easily yeah 100 cause like
i did not expect them to age you know in
the first five minutes of the damn
episode
no i don't think anybody did
wait so who did monica call that one
scene daniel diaz thanks for the demo i
don't know
i don't know dude this is going to be an
episode that we're going to be
re-watching
non-stop like non-stop this is probably
the most jam-packed episode
of things to break down easily
because we haven't even talked about
like all of the little easter eggs that
we're all going to be finding
within these next couple of days
what is happening to my
my stream's all messed up right now
someone said read richard says the
astrophysicist
yeah i mean that seems to be like uh
yo imagine if they imagine if they
introduced reed richards
in this show yeah that would be insane
and then i mean
that could be the actor that paul benton
wanted to talk about right
oh my god the the luke cameo is john
krasinski
right i mean uh do you think paul
bettany would want to work with him
that's my question though right i mean
yeah um
wanda sam's thank you for the donor said
juan has had a slight russian accent
when she came out of the bubble
the accent was back like it was almost
like she forgot everything she learned
yeah when she was with the avengers yeah
she lost all empathy and all the good in
her
by the way i'm looking at this shot
again a vision
in the sword facility and it's literally
his
it looks like his uh left arm
his right arm his his left leg right leg
his torso
yeah they're all like detached
oh dude yeah
so that goes back to um the vision quest
story where his body's all separated and
she has to go back and she has to like
actually search for all of his body
parts and like
collect them bottom dollars outdoor
thanks for the demo
there will someone that comes into the
show that shows where the future's
heading yeah
someone green green caesar 55 thanks for
the donut
um i i want to say
bro nothing is off the table anymore
we've been seeing that but now
it just again like they prove it once
again nothing is off the table
did she
man i want to know how pedro came back
i don't even care that it's not the same
version okay 12 52.
they said 12 52 there's like a drawing
on the fridge of like a fiery figure
12 52. yeah i see that in the back
uh oh yeah i see it i don't know what
that is
it's definitely a fiery figure i'm only
a fiery figure but
but we're still confirmed right
yo by the way 666
the boy's all here i know oh my gosh
this is insane
oh wait eddie terrell wanda calls agnes
when she needed
help makes sense later when vision
awakens her in the car
yeah absolutely eddie and thank you for
the dono do we think
hey nisha thanks for the initiating
thanks for the donut missing person is
evan peters character
oh i don't know i i don't know
but you know now that pietro's back in
the mix
dude they could bring back quicksilver
and mcu like they could make this the
mainstream quicksilver oh yeah for sure
they might and they might just do that
because i think
because i i can't remember which episode
it was
but i had the the thought that
since the whole clothes clothing change
thing i'm glad that they addressed this
on this video or in this episode
i'm glad they did because i thought like
well okay so things are changing when
you go in
like what happens when you go out and
if vision we know now that she kind of
put him back together and
made him come back to life but if she
would have had like the twins
they're real in reality they go outside
of
the bubble right it's kind of like we're
talking about vision if he leaves like
do they
disintegrate like what happens what
happens to the twins when
when when they leave right and there's
no more shield barrier or anything like
that
like what happens i'm still not
really convinced that
it's wanda completely doing everything
i'm sure
yeah same because remember how we talked
about i don't know if this last time or
the time before that
you know she she it's almost like you
know it's actually almost like what we
talked about last time she went she got
vision's body
and maybe she's like driving to new
jersey and just like his mental
breakdown
and then and then boom but the way
that monica said and she stopped it by
putting up that barrier
i wonder if it wasn't really her like if
it was like
it was her but she could tell like this
isn't me this is like the scarlet witch
in me
almost you know what i'm saying almost
like the phoenix force is like a
different thing
but particularly she even said she even
said division at the end she's like
i don't know how this whole thing
started right exactly
now you could go the mental
trauma route right and
just i'm i'm almost i almost want to say
that the scarlet witch
is like her alter ego that takes over
sometimes
yeah right kind of like the hulk right
yeah
because what is i don't remember the
exact quote
but you know it's confirmed that we're
they're gonna call her the scarlet witch
and i thought they were
i thought that's what the director was
saying like what was her name
does she have a nickname or anything
like exactly
she's gonna be called scarlet witch by
the end of this show right oh for sure i
think
she's gonna be the one to give her that
name though
because i think scarlet witch is gonna
come out
like warren said yeah and she's going to
be the one to say
she's i'm scarlet witch right i think i
think next episode when she's dressed in
her iconic like comic accurate costume
yeah
maybe agnes will say something like oh
look you're dressed as a scarlet witch
right
madaga madoga73 thank you so much for
the donation
oh i just missed monica has powers now
she changed like her clothes randy
burnside thank you for the donation
i think she has powers now i do too
yeah all because of the medical report
yeah that's the only reason why
and uh back to the note on the aerospace
engineer
you know the the most famous engineers
in
the the marvel universe go as such
not in any particular order victor von
doom
peter parker otto octavius
tony stark hank pym
hank mccoy forge
shuri and none other than reed richards
bro i i think it's one of them for sure
gotta be one of the people you just
mentioned
yeah for sure i honestly i mean
i think reed richards makes the most
sense sure would also make sense
um for obvious reasons but
hank mccoy would be pretty up here beast
yeah
pretty wild oh wait yeah i ever
thanks for the donation and good point i
wanted to bring this up he says
when vision awakened norm he only said
said
she he never said wanda yeah i thought i
thought i was like
to me yeah i was like that's so specific
he didn't say wanda
i thought all right so then it could be
agnes yeah
yeah i think so too that's it that's a
really clever
wording is like right yeah yeah green
season 5 thanks for the dono
at 9 45 to talk about juana's parents no
connection to magneto
uh not based off of what i heard
um because i actually knew the names
before
just from a league
and yeah i did it um glenn
cottingham on my supreme sentinel a
super chat put
vision didn't need to wake up agnes he
won't have to next week
she'll be messing with him she's won
wanda's handler for mephisto
and we know in the halloween episode
we're going to get that scene where
vision kind of
awakens agnes in the car bro she's
stroking
she's stroking this whole thing she's
broken the fire she's going tell vision
that he's dead
right and that's what he doesn't know so
when he finds out that he's dead
that's right yeah because
yeah he doesn't remember anything and
everything's gonna
he's gonna lose it and that's probably
when he tries to escape
yeah oh this is a good place outside of
west view
this is a good point uh sweetie puma
thanks for the donation
i think she might have subconsciously
ripped the multiverse open
and brought quicksilver into the mcu
from the fox universe it's very very
possible
that she is ripping it open but kind of
doesn't know she is or you know the same
the same thing like maybe scarlet witch
james a pierced iii
thank you so much for the donation but
yeah maybe it's
i don't know i i'm with brad 100
agatha is control she's poking
at it right she's poking at it and it's
you know
she is i'm a group brad she doesn't need
to be awakened or
i agree with uh what your super chat
said
i i don't think she needs to be awakened
and i
think brad is right she's messing with
vision
maybe i don't know because in the
trailer
like it's very clear that he like
touches her and there's like the the
like the yellow energy that goes into
her head and stuff like that
so she's a bro she's a powerful witch
she can
make it look like whatever she wants you
know that's true you're not wrong there
like like she's she's definitely
manipulating this
uh and stirring the pot and really
pushing
wanda over the edges but vision for sure
he's like a sleeper agent he's
he's unaware of anything that's
happening and she
keeps informing him of all this stuff
yeah
and the message who sent the message was
that sword or was that agnes
right to vision
you know that's something to think about
too
if the clothes stay permanent when they
leave the bubble
why wouldn't the kids revision stay
permanent no i agree with you and thanks
for the
the donation and that was like uh that's
what we were talking about i
i think whatever she creates in this
reality is going to
stay yeah like the twins
but i'm still going back to what brett
what we're talking about before
with the director trying to kill wanda
yeah there's definitely an ulterior
motive like the director is corrupt
like he's he's he's corrupt for sure
i i want to say yes but i feel like it's
just too obvious like they're really
putting it out there
like they showed us today he's not cool
right
we don't know if he's like evil but we
know he's not cool like
oh what's her name like oh oh yeah this
destruction in lagos and killing those
people
yo but they could just be setting him up
to like literally be
someone she just like unleashes hell on
and she actually kills him
maybe that's what i'm saying i'm not
sure
just because it's so obvious if he is
somebody really are you i
thank you so much for the donation
because you know how it is right it's
like
when you if the person's too obvious
it's not the person
yeah i i think he's another misdirection
kind of like dottie
was at the beginning um although dotty
exactly so you know it's very possible
that he's there to
kind of pull our vision away from
certain things or assume he's mephisto
or somebody else
um i i think he's just a dick like
right right right maybe he's just yeah
and i think he's an idiot because
clearly you're not gonna kill wanda with
a missile out of a drone
what did you think you were gonna do
like she's controlling
a thousand people with her mind yeah and
that
that was the coolest aspect of that
backstory with this whole thing is
for them to admit that's what she's
doing
right right or it might be agnes too we
we don't know yet
but wanda didn't deny that she was
controlling
norm right in front of her right so
that's another thing too where it's like
she didn't say she wasn't doing it
yeah you know so it's it's you know but
also
once again this is my world stay out of
it
right you know yeah so she's controlling
uh a lot of it
let's put it that way oh i 100 agree oh
yeah yeah yeah
guys look at 8 26 there was like a split
second of one
that we've never seen before and it was
like when wanda was talking
or no monica was talking about how
painful it was to be under the mind
control it was like
wanda like crying at 8 26
and for the the people asking in my chat
about the commercial
august was the place in civil war where
wanda blew up the hospital
right yeah yeah i just want to
acknowledge james a pierce thanks for
the donation james appears the third
what about the captain marvel shade from
monica did you catch that
i don't know if it was shade
because i think obviously her her and
captain marvel have like have huge like
connection
but there was something weird there i
will say that what what time stamp we're
looking at right now oh 8 26
8 26 1 it's like crying like breaking
down bro
i have it on my screen
it's like present day oh yeah yeah yo
that's it that's where she make that's
the way this all gets created that's the
breakdown we were talking about in new
jersey with the body
bro dude if i just he called
it bro we literally
called it like what last week
yeah that's how that has to be what that
is
so 8 26 there's like a half seconds
like half a second thing of wanda
that's where she breaks down that's
where it goes i bet you we can go so
check those street lights out i bet you
we can [ __ ] i bet you we can go
i bet you we can go um and find him in
westfield
bet you 100 here i'll do it right now
i'll i'll try to find where's the dogs
wow what a catch good job guys
good stuff ladies and gentlemen this is
why these watch parties are literally
the best bro
and that's what's so great about this
show is they keep going back
and giving further information about how
we got to this point right
so we're gonna actually see wanda
completely lose it
yeah and that is going to be
unbelievable
but i also think someone's there
stirring the pot
well 1 000 someone there is is
definitely
pushing her over the edge yeah you're
not gonna convince me that there's not
another person
that we haven't seen yet and
i think it's more than just agnes i
think
i think i don't think access does it by
herself
yo they're the same lights
same street lights that's it because if
you look at
where is this 2713
you can see like the bubble shaped
lights hold on i gotta acknowledge some
donations
sriram sitharaman i'm sorry if i can't
pronounce that but thank you so much for
the nation troll gaming tv
director could be a scroll because in
spider-man 2. it's the same
nick left scroll yeah that's true
michael kaminski thanks for the donut
monica got her powers
x-ray confirm yeah i think so
uh milka earns xantas thank you so much
for the donation
thank you yo guys this is freaking crazy
we call this last week
wyatt guys we've been calling this this
is why these watch parties are the best
we're the we're the best thing to get
we're just calling this choice
crap 100
wow oh yeah um another thing too is that
um
you guys know about that like mystery
actor that we know is gonna be in like
the later episodes of world vision where
he he's gonna be like a gay character
yeah what happened to like one of the
kids um
someone said um that there was like a
rainbow
in the kitchen and like that's like an
allusion to like one of the kids being
gay
oh yeah what's up yeah relationship
connor greenway
i'm sorry if you if i missed your donut
but thank you so so so so much
yeah because i i don't remember where he
originally heard that from but yeah i
mean in the comics he's gay
oh yeah conor greenway so sorry i missed
that i think monica called reed richards
since
she said this person is an aerospace
engineer he is a person
in marvel who started the fantastic four
i mean yeah
um bro it would make so much sense it
would make sense and
i want it to be true right
i mean i want it to be true i want it i
mean
okay let's let's take a step back
kevin feige has said and i always found
this particular
we have we're working on a feature
now is what he said now
in my mind if you're working on a
feature
you have pretty much everything ready
for it brad you know more than
we would right if they're working on a
feature now they've announced the
project
do they have actors already to play the
part oh 100
right and what's a little
i'm assuming it might be not a
no maybe a post-credit scene but you
know
a minute of airtime right i mean what's
it take to film that right nothing right
so it's like
yeah a super close set you could film it
inside a room
right i mean and it's literally just
like him at his desk
like i don't know like getting alerted
of everything that's happening
yeah rui thanks for the donation wanda
is dealing in magic there are rules
being broken
one is definitely messing up the
multiverse by pulling things in the west
view
i would agree with that a hundred
percent
oh someone sent in a super chat
shout out priyanj thank you for the
super chat brother
but they put um what if billy and tommy
are
mephisto and grim reaper dang that would
be intense
that would be wild that'd be so dark
29.8 the lights yeah man
again guys we saw it we saw it all with
um
wanda breaks down in the middle of
jersey yeah
that's the biggest thing what where was
that again i want to go back to it
you know i still can't get over that
shot of
wanda envision the living room man that
scene was intense
we've never seen a vision that upset
before man ever bro he was heated he was
ready to screw up
dude he really was and
i like that he's humanized now and he's
just like
i don't remember anything before this
like
yeah not just a little calm like
synthezoid that has like zero feelings
like
no he there's like there's there's
someone in there
right and brad i think it kind of goes
into that theory that vision
is wanda's good conscience yeah
the one that we know and love would
would be questioning all of this
right coming to her senses yeah
milka earns xantas thanks for the donut
we can brought patreon
that's why he has a recast you know i
you know we've talked about that tonight
and i
i don't know if we can brought because
the only thing is is i don't know
i'm not actually sure
are the twins controlling their aging or
is it agnes right
and what and what more do they have
control
over uh
i don't know if wiccan brought her back
it obviously it's a
huge possibility that happened but let's
just say agnes was rather chill
drinking her liquor yeah she watched the
kids age up to five in a harpy
yeah yeah nothing nothing nothing good
she did
spray that stuff on them and so here's a
good point though
spectra thanks for the donation can
someone please explain how the kids
knew wanda could bring things back from
the dead what do they know and how do
they know it and that's a really good
question
how do they know all these things
because
14 are they are they
bad people but i'll go 73 thanks for the
nation appreciate it
are they mephisto and the grim reaper
and they're poking at her
and that she that's in their heads i
think is emma caufield
i church pastor blaster thanks for the
don't know who is emma caulfield
do you guys know who that is oh my god
bro
what what the hell evan peters
what's how's this real life
the silver hair and everything
also the other thing i found interesting
is when the director
was at the table and he was like i've
just received clearance to show you this
who gave him clearance yeah and
he's just boss yeah so are you fury
it would have to be i mean it would make
sense
that's what i'm saying so it did fury
was very updated to the point where he's
like yeah maybe we should uh
let them know oh what's really happening
warren someone said that emma caulfield
is dotty
but i don't think she is i'm looking at
her right now i guess she is
i guess she is so i had that thought too
there's like voices in their head right
mirror yeah i guess it is dottie okay
yeah yeah it is her okay good good cook
yeah topa made tope amade aerospace
engineer equals john brzezinski thanks
for the donation
yeah i think he could and i think he
could be introduced at the end of this
and then maybe tie into ant-man 3
and then there's the fantastic four
movie after 100
100 directors mephisto yeah we've been
theorizing that the director is
definitely
he's someone man whether it's he's a
scroll or he's mephisto
or there's something going on with that
director he's
us bro i'm re-watching when when wanda
comes out
of the the pocket reality man and she's
just there's nothing there
you know yeah like they're like her soul
is gone her emotions are gone her
empathy is gone
like yeah she's like even her accent
isn't the same
no i feel like it's it's it's different
where it's not
you know the the good and bad it's just
straight bad
yeah like i i feel like she this is a
different version
of of wanda altogether ergo the scarlet
witch
well then when monica tries to appeal to
that
good side doesn't work at all she's like
what can you do to help me
like i'm the freaking scarlet witch you
know what i mean like
man get her thank you for the super chat
bottom dollar outdoors thanks for the
super chat deadpool knocks on to where
this opens the door deadpool says
i'm looking for a big random blue hat yo
okay in all honesty i think if anything
would make me lose my mind
deadpool would have made me lose my mind
sean webb thanks for supporting i want
to be surprised
twins remind me of the shining they
actually kind of do
it's very interesting someone someone in
my chat angel thank you for the super
chat they brought up that
um fury is in space during
um like in spider-man far from home
which is months after end game where as
well on the business is only a few weeks
so like
fury could still play a role in this he
he maybe he's not inside
check this out so
i just had this thought because the
scroll have been bad in the comics
forever
now marvel's maybe what if marvel's just
making us think they're good
because talos is nick fury right now
so what if talos gave the director
permission to show it
what if the director is a scroll and the
scroll are working together and they're
trying to get rid of some of the
powerful people who could get in their
way
i mean i i'm i'm trying i'm just trying
to see the scrolls be bad already you
know
like we all we all know they're going to
be bad at some point super scroll where
are you at
for real do you think monica is wrong
do you think monica holds captain marvel
responsible for maria getting her cancer
hence her anger reaction to jimmy saying
her name i'm not sure ross blake thanks
for the doughnut
um someone said they didn't sword break
the sokovia accords
by um dismembering him
well they they mentioned something about
his final wishes
you know something like that i don't
know
guys why why is wanda so aggressive
towards monica
like when when monica starts walking
towards her outside
she's like oh you're still here yeah
yeah she starts she's like
she's ready to throw something at monica
but why yeah like
why is she threatened by monica rambo
that's my question like what what is it
with
monica that threatens her to the point
where she's not worried about the guns
drawn
but she's worried about a uh a woman
who's walking at her without any weapons
an unarmed woman like uh you know what
what is
the reason why is she so angry right
and why kingsley the king thanks for
dino agnes was around
every time the twins age and she never
said anything
but to that point she actually wanda
actually brought her powers out
against monica didn't it to the
anything else what was with
what was with that whole energy scene at
the end or right at that part what was
what
you know like something came over the
bubble and she like you know
hypnotized the guys and they all turned
on the director what was that all
i hate that wanda's powers are red
because if they weren't i'd be like
but i don't know if it's you know what i
mean because i can say it but i'm not
sure
because her powers are
yeah ultron is in the one division cast
on google
also the x-men and mc going to join
xander
7 thanks for the donation yeah the only
problem with that is is
depending on things that you can pay for
and
you can get access and change that like
google also said uh hugh jackman's
wolverine was an avengers end game but
i missed him if he was um
michael thank you for the super chat
michael said um to me monica had a very
similar reaction to the mention of
captain marvel as nick fury
talos in spider-man far from home
don't invoke that name
yeah yeah malik brad rad someone said
what if agnes killed the dog because the
dog is doctor strange
bro i'm telling you man uh agnes is
suss well and and she mentioned ralph
again where the heck is wrong
dude ralph is mephisto
i'm sorry ralph is my first time what
are you gonna pull up last second
yeah i guess it's gonna be like okay so
let's meet my husband
here's my question now at this point
guys
wanda threatened and nearly killed
almost all the sword people in this
episode yeah okay
so now at this point i think it's very
clear that your little drones and
missiles aren't going to do anything
it's not to bring in the big ones bro
next week's episode they gotta have a
response team
okay like they have to like th this
it's the only logical move at this point
yeah it's time to bring in her family
yeah like someone yeah someone that she
at least can look at and and communicate
and recognize because right now she
doesn't know any of these people
none of them except vision everybody
else is foreign to her
so bring in a familiar face like hawkeye
this is like
uh this is like justice league when they
brought in lois lane for supes
yeah 100 and and that that would be
interesting to see how she reacts to
that
especially i'm telling you if the
hawkeye thing happens oh yeah
i think it's gonna happen for sure lose
his hearing new cabbage leaf thanks for
the donut what if rap is director
i think ralph could be the director
because i think the director could be
mephisto well my only deal is is i think
it's too in my face
for him to be the villain
right it could be a villain but i think
they're they're very
i think they're very upfront
that he's kind of bad and not all good
yeah they're trying to hide it the way
they are ralph yeah
maddie ice awesome name mephisto has
shape-shifting abilities so he
turned into quicksilver that's why juana
was confused when she opened the door
thanks for the dono
yeah i mean can you imagine um
evan peters memphis though i'd be wild
i think it is man
the ozlog thanks for the donut was
hawkeye coming happy b
day to my homie sego
bob i think hawkeye is coming that's
what we're talking about
what about monica's lab reports there
was nothing on her scans did she change
is she super yeah i think we all we're
just like yeah
i think going through it activated
something or gave it to her
um especially that's the thing too hold
on let's already interrupt
she wanda was like wait you're still
alive
you know so she was kind of surprised so
maybe
she was trying to kill her and because
she had the mutant gene
that's what saved her maybe but but
monica
said that she also saved her at the same
time which
leads me to go back to the scarlet witch
wanda theater
yeah where it's both yeah hey
this this is amazing that um that
one sock nugget sent in a 10 super chat
they put them
hold up they put at 14 10
you can read the newspaper and it talks
about the lights in the sky
do you think that's just the veil or
something else what do you guys think
maybe the drones um maybe um
i don't know thanks for the super chat
here i don't know we can see the
newspaper here yeah
hi i'm vivek from india love your
channel god bless everybody all right
4k subs let's go
oh agnes is wearing her pin again
someone said oh oh snap
that's funny someone said imagine um and
during the moment where
wanda enters the sword facility you hear
like the x-men quicksilver music
hold on i might have seen something
dude i think pietro might be mephisto
we just got to see how he acts moving
forward with like the
next episode next couple of episodes
yeah but i think there's there's a
chance that pietro might be mephisto i
think he might be a mephisto i
i really do
gary lopez why would mephisto go through
the trouble of recasting quicksilver
couldn't he just shape-shift
into that world's version of pietro
thanks for the donut and yeah i mean
yeah i don't know that's that that part
is actually racking my brain right now
as to why it's a different version and
the fact that it doesn't look like juan
is the one that brought him back
trevza thanks for the donut look at
mirror at 33 23 it's all warped
hiding quicksilver what
33 23 this is just absolutely insane
oh oh whoa whoa wait a second hold on
what did i just see
what what's this timestamp what's this
33-23 when she opens the door to
quicksilver there's a mirror in the
background
yeah someone said a red hand i saw
that's what i that's what i think i just
saw
it kinda looks like it
it's hard to see i couldn't see it
that's why i didn't really call it out
like when i went back to 33-23
yeah it's like i i feel like i do see it
33-23 i mean go
you know just hit like the space bar
over and over again so it goes like
super slowly
oh sh yeah oh yeah
no i totally see it oh my gosh i don't
know
i don't know it's tough is that a normal
hand or is it red
well oh it's red bro it's red it's gotta
be red right
it's red oh my god i'm seeing a picture
of that guys i screenshotted that
yeah i i think he is mephisto
oh my god i'm not seeing it so it's
he takes like a step forward and he
moves and you have to pause it
uh brad brad look at me
this scene you see the mirror in the
background yeah that
it's like very hard to see but that's
when you that's where you'll find it
all i see is wanda's arm yeah if you
just like in the space bar and go frame
by frame
his head kind of moves for like a half a
second his head moves for like half a
second
it's super fast okay i see i see what
you're talking about now spectra thanks
for the ten dollars
yeah super chat yo and this goes back to
what we talked about
like a month ago soups about uh mephisto
having red skin the slick back hair and
yeah
yeah that that looks potentially like a
black suit but he is wearing a black
jacket if that is true
yo and another thing too um someone in
my chat mentioned which would be
pretty crazy and it would kind of like
invoke
that reaction by maria um
when they when they mentioned captain
marvel but they said what if maria got
cancer because of captain marvel's
radiation yeah that's what somebody said
on mine too in the super chat
could be spectra thanks for the 10
dono also the change of she went home to
she didn't belong here about monica
and the previous one the kids
yeah i don't know about the kids knowing
that she can resurrect
that that's that's strange to me i'll
tell jp
dottie is the director's wife oh montel
jb
that might be something that's why he's
sent his best engine and monica to get
her back
well monica kind of got sucked in right
so i don't think he sent her in kenneth
all the very things for the donut what
happened to the beekeeper
they said a man and nobody asked about
him did the director send a squirrel
i don't know what happened to the
beekeeper i actually wondered that
because we never saw what happened when
she kind of like
re wound or rewrote time i hope they
explain that
because that's actually kind of like
wrecking my brain as well guys it looks
like a red hand
yeah that's a red hand bro i just
literally i opened full screen
and i screenshotted it and now i just
put my
well i just put my brightness all the
way up and it freaking looks red
and if you compare it to to his skin to
her skin
if you compare it to his skin and her
skin it's it
yeah holy crap man would they do that
wait hey whoa whoa whoa whoa wait a
second
wait a second what is wait time out
in the same frame what is going across
from wanda's like hair to the guy's
shoulder it looks like
something
i don't know no because i was thinking
that's his outside arm not his inside
arm
it is his outside arm that looks like a
grim reaper arm in all honesty
maybe i'm stretching but what is that
they brought up visions wishes as not
being a weapon as a clue to him turning
into ultron after leaving westview
without the mind stone he's ultron oh
maybe
the [ __ ] um i think i'm convinced now
that
quicksilver is yeah
just because of that one shot dude his
hand is clearly red
yeah but also that
that little black thing that's going
across from him to her
yeah that's super weird i can't make out
what that is it looks like a grim reaper
armed me
is what like the scythe you talking
about the scythe
no just like a skeleton arm
like like like the actual grim reaper
not the one from the comics like you
know what i mean like with the cloak and
everything
like a skeleton arm almost like holding
him
for whatever reason the hand is red
right i'm going to say a screenshot that
looks red yeah
you saw it yeah i mean hand looks very
very red uh
guys i think evan peters because i i'm
still
trying to figure this out why is it evan
peters
it doesn't make sense why is it evan and
they
noted it marvel made fun of it darcy
said
did she recast pedro
my god dude this is pandemonium so it
could
literally be quick
it could literally be something happened
and i hate aaron taylor johnson
bringing evan peters right i mean
it that could very well have happened
because
from what we knew he had you know a
couple of
a few movies on his contract and he only
did one
so like who knows what happened
oh man this is crazy
drake gerald's what if mephisto has been
a few different people since he can
shapeshift i mean
yeah right a bunch of different towns
people
somebody said in here so i don't
remember the name the grim reaper you
know killed sparky
and if if agnes was wearing you know the
grim reaper
pin meaning that she works with him
yeah i mean because she had sparky right
without the mindstone vision would just
be jarvis not ultron they got ultron
from the mine stone
well
kind of ultron was the
kind of the program that tony had
designed
to you know be like the end-all but the
mind stone definitely affected it and
kind of made it you know
i'm gonna have to rewatch some things
all right boys i love you to death but i
have a call in the morning
and i have to get started wait hold on
hold on hold on
somebody just said something it made a
lot of sense krishna soda
evan peters lives in the 80s in the in
his x-men universe and this is an
80s episode of one division
remember i said that yeah said it
maybe that's why but
like no offense to evan peters but is he
a caliber actor to play memphis so i
don't know
i i've seen the fan art of him and it
looks good
um i don't know but um
we're talking about the devil okay
yeah and i i still think well okay
so before i thought uh uh
paul bettany was talking about
the this famous actor is going to come
in i thought he was talking about
mephisto right
and now i think you might be talking
about like john krasinski
or somebody like that so i don't i don't
know so i don't i don't know if uh
the stained glass on the door means
something bottom dollar outdoors thanks
for the
donations i love this show
that hand is red man i appreciate you
guys i'm out of here
i should get some sleep i gotta keep
your call in the morning appreciate you
boys
soups what we got ourselves into
right we got a long night this is
amazing
we got a long night and it's the longest
episode we've gotten so far
yeah dude 42 i do i saw 42 minutes and i
was like yes
yeah yes
so guys with that being said i'm gonna
cap the live stream here thank you guys
for watching
our one division episode 5 watch party
warren
brad and i will be back over here to
break down episode six
the halloween episode next week it's
gonna be just as crazy as this one
this episode was pretty crazy i have
videos to make so with that being said
i love you guys 3 thousand and i'll see
you guys next time peace
see you soon
wow okay so
i want to acknowledge the super chat
real quick
elijah bell what if the mailman has some
connection to agnes or
not his maybe he's swords or delivers
the scripts ooh
elijah bell i like that and thank you
for the donation i think the mailman
meant something it'd be weird to just
like
put such emphasis on somebody bottom
dollar outdoors i'm gonna have to look
into that
thanks for the donut i'm trying to get
the donuts here
what am i missing if we get to the 90s
and the intros not a full house that
would be mad
rc blue i know right and thank you for
the donation
blackhawk pictures 23 thanks for the 5
donut when pedro steps forward
at 33 23 the mirror reflection doesn't
move at all
also look closely yeah i do i did notice
that
um some of the characters do have a red
glow around them
and it's very interesting and i'm
confused because
if it is wanda controlling them
then it's her red right
but i don't know
i don't know guys i got a lot of work to
do because i gotta break down a video
now but it looks like
in a very weird way the x-men are now on
the mcu
so
okay
other reality these have been splitted
the realities have been
splitted
dang all right guys this was super
awesome i love these watch parties
i wish i could stream it all uh watch
the new promo i will i wish i could
stream it all but
man um
gosh so much happened tonight so many
times tonight it's crazy it's crazy
i i mean from mephisto to the grim
reaper to it being wanda who's the
actual villain there's so much
that just could be happening and it's
like absolutely insane but i gotta go
guys i gotta record these videos i gotta
break down
this episode so i gotta watch it a few
more times and um
look for my video in the morning gonna
break down the whole thing thank you all
so much
for joining me in the live stream
they're super awesome and you guys make
it
really really awesome